Creating a watch face for
Android Wear is an exercise centered
around visualizing time clearly.
It's quite different than designing
an Android user interface.
Android Wear devices provide a unique
way to reimagine the ways in which we
tell time.
Android Wear also let's you integrate
data on watch interfaces for
a high level of personalization and
contextual relevance.
These are powerful tools
to create watch faces, but
they also run the risk of over
complicating your design.
The most successful watch face designs
take advantage of these advanced
capabilities, but deliver
information clearly and elegantly.
Glancability is the single most
important principle to consider when
creating a watch face design.
Your watch face design should clearly
show time and any related data.
Experiment with bold, minimal and
expressive designs that are highly
readable at a distance.